on retrouve on sur place l'envoyé
spécial de france 24 joe natale walsh
vous êtes bons jours déjà alors vous
êtes allé hier sur la ligne de front
vient de voir votre reportage qui s'est
déroulée donc dans le nord-est de la
capitale vous avez vu donc des
militaires équipe est organisée pour
faire face on vient de le voir à
l'avancé des rues semble
oui c'est résistance on a pu l'observer
sur ce sur ce verrou stratégique
nord-est mais visiblement c'est un peu
le même scénario au nord ouest dans la
zone de butch à dire pin même si un
désastre humanitaire également lieu dans
le même temps la population de ces
localités a fui il y avait cent dix
mille habitants avant la guerre dans
cette dans cette zone havas il kiffe
également où nous nous sommes rendus à
une quarantaine de kilomètres au sud de
kiev la résistance semble forte et la
ville était été assez calme et
visiblement bien défendu quand nous nous
sommes rendus sur place il y a quelques
jours après il ne faut pas non plus
sous-estimer la capacité
la capacité des russes en cas de
bombardement de début des bombardements
plus intensif sur la sur les capitales
pour l'instant il semble que c'est une
certes d'une sorte de guerre
psychologique qui se joue ici il y à des
bombardements sporadiques avec peu de
destruction sur des sur des immeubles
résidentiels mais pour l'instant pas
plus que ça dans le centre ville de la
capitale ukrainienne les russes
johnattan qui tente depuis des semaines
de se rapprocher de kiev peut-être même
de l'encercler mais pour l'instant il
semble ne plus progresser
écoutez pour l'instant oui il semble il
semble bloquée sur c'est sur ces points
stratégiques que que je viens de citer
et puis surtout il ya toujours cet axe
sud de la capitale qui est dégagée nous
l'avons emprunté hier pour revenir sur
la capitale après le juste après le
couvre-feu et on a pu observer que cette
ces taxes cette ligne était vraiment
très bien défendu et nous avons croisé
de nombreux barrages de nombreux
checkpoints et la présence militaire la
présence des volontaires est très forte
et il ya encore dans toujours cet axe
ouvert et qui permet à la fois
d'efforts de la capitale de faire de
faire venir des militaires des forces
armées et puis aussi il faut pas
l'oublier de ravitailler kiev puisque
malgré tout la capitale est
partiellement encerclée et c'est un
souci ici pour la population que l'on
voit souvent faire la queue devant les
supermarchés ou devant les pharmacies
par exemple merci jonathan watch envoyé
spécial de france 24 à kiev la capitale